wally what are you doing up there i
tried to text you but my phone died my
phone died
that's it i didn't mean to scare you i
swear i'm down here right now not you
you stay up there
[Music]
there's one option but the operation is
risky so when you're having surgery i
don't know how do i tell my daughter
i'm kind of it for her
so how are you
let's go somewhere we've never taken a
real road trip together no way it's the
rest of summer we're going i will be
miserable the entire time i will teach
you to drive on the way if you have a
good attitude for real i'll let you get
behind the wheel if you promise to never
do that again ever i will never ever do
it again get out
all right good
we're gonna see so much good stuff
driving when you look back on this trip
i want you to remember you and me
spending time together not you waiting
for your boyfriend to come
[Music]
i need you to drive i didn't know your
headaches were this fun you never tell
me anything
clear go now did you close your eyes
no always keep your eyes open one second
okay
is this what a midlife crisis is no
yes
i'd bet on you i want you for my whole
life
you have a fire inside your wallet life
is gonna pull some moves to try and put
it out trust yourself
[Music]
[Music]
you